you need stories for the people the
people who are who are growing up in
afghanistan don't have any national
unity the story that they're told that
the kids growing up is the americans
invaded and took over and now we live
under their rule what great story so you
know when i'm a kid and i'm growing up i
see that photo of iwo jima and they're
raising the flag and you know never
forget and all of these things these
things meant to inspire and tell kids
that's what you want to be like that's
what you aspire to be
what do they have in afghanistan if
they're not if they're you're growing up
and you're like we were conquered
right what what so
but they were celebrating with the
taliban well they didn't that's not the
story they told them what they told them
was that
empires alexander is great the russians
the americans they all come here and
they all lose son son we're just waiting
them out
yeah what and i don't want to use this
cliche because it's so cliched and
everybody uses it but they're like son
they got watches we got time oh yeah
that's the thing if you're going to
colonize mountains a desert mountain
then you need to import food and that's
going to cost you trillions and
trillions of dollars you need to import
water that's another trip but for 80
years you've got to fund that thing it's
going to be an 80 year project three
centuries if you want that to happen the
the fundamental error here is that we in
our progressive era politics and foreign
policy and modernity and all these
things that we think we can change
everyone around the world if they could
just listen to us and learn our ways
they will improve and change and
whatever and our arrogance led us to
believe that not only were we going to
just go to like a country that was like
a step below us and just kind of bring
them up to where we were no we were
going to go to the most bass ackwards
place in the entire world with a
civilization more antithetical to ours
than any other in existence
and try to bring them up to 2021
wokeness
is that is the height of folly i i i'll
say what i think
what country is uh uh
to the west of afghanistan we mentioned
it but i'm asking again oh my god i
don't know there's there's like there's
pakistan and iran and iraq and there and
china's over they're all over there
somewhere to the west of afghanistan why
are you putting me on the side
i'm just doing this as like a [ __ ]
everyone should do this you should look
at a map look at a map and get familiar
with the area right the country directly
west of afghanistan is iran okay there
we go do you know what country is
directly east of iraq
iran iran yeah and so when you look at
what john bolton's been saying that we
will be celebrating victory in tehran by
this time next year instead of a couple
of years ago it sounds to me like the
purpose of afghanistan is not
to to create a nation necessarily but to
create a stronghold where we can supply
troops and have military infrastructure
because they wanted to invade iran oh
well that's absolutely true that was all
part of the neocon domino's falling
theory that they put forth
after
after we decided to invade okay that's
the part that people forget i believe is
that we decided to invade afghanistan
and then iraq before wolfowitz and the
neocons had fully formulated their
spreading democracy concept i believe
that the spreading democracy concept
came after the urge to invade
afghanistan and iraq but this is me
going back 20 years and trying to
remember the news report news reports at
the time i was in grad school so we were
talking about this quite a bit
and uh i just remember wolfowitz and the
neocons formulating the spreading of the
democracy and the domino's falling
theory after it was already determined
by bush's rhetoric going
he would he would do this word smash
where he would go uh iraq uh al qaeda
911 afghanistan saddam hussein iraq
weapons of mass destruction afghanistan
iraq saddam hussein terror terror and he
would just he would just mash all those
words up together without any logical
coherence but he would just say them
together in a rhythm in such a way that
everyone began to associate
all those concepts together al qaeda
afghanistan i'm saying weapons mass
destruction iraq ah 9 11. ah more of
this is going to happen oh we have to
defend ourselves that was that was the
the banging of the war drums at that
time and i believe that the academic
infrastructure for all this the
wolfowitz led neocon theory abdominal
falling and such
my my memory could be wrong and i was
younger then for sure was that that came
after afterwards and became the
justification for this prolonged
experience that we had there that of
course the military industrial complex
gets behind they're like yeah we can
sell more bombs you know i'm really
really impressed by you got to give it
to the united states the power and the
prowess of their armed forces in being
able to stage an invasion of a country
less than a month after the terror
attack that happened which was the
reason for that attack so we invaded
afghanistan in october of 2001 october
7th 2001 so that means 9 11 a month 9 11
happens
george w bush says we know who did it
he reached out to the taliban and says
hand over osama bin laden they said give
us proof he says we don't need proof we
know he's guilty i'm paraphrasing but
that's like near near accurate quote
yeah and then in less than a month the
u.s had the resources and the strategic
positions to invade a country i mean
that is
that is wow
they've been at this for for decades and
days are you insinuating that 9 11 was
an inside job meant to determine to set
us on some foreign policy excursion no i
think george w bush wanted to invade
afghanistan no matter what happened and
after 9 11 happened he was like well
afghanistan or iraq i would i would
actually iraq was later no daddy i know
iraq in the 90s so i remember their
arguments back then because i'm a little
bit older than you guys and i remember
them saying like all this is about
george bush avenging his daddy and so
maybe maybe in his mind and i don't know
i'm totally speculating i know people
who know this so maybe i should just ask
them but uh you know maybe he when he
got in office he's like we gotta fix
this thing in iraq
and then 911 happened and it was like oh
we'll do this then we'll do that i'm
saying they wanted to invade already
like they they they were they were they
just wanted we had we had uh
they they talked about it we had in the
invasion in the 90s they wanted to go in
the neocons wanted they wanted
to invade and i was saying that we we
were very quick in our like what i mean
to say is we we we waited no time right
we didn't say like let's have
international hearings let's let's let's
get a third a third nation involved to
to make demands of the taliban let's put
international pressure it was like less
than a month i was like send in the
troops we didn't go after bin laden we
set up a nation building
yeah part of the project we did but then
we let him go and let him go to practice
but uh i'll push back on one thing you
said there uh they definitely formed an
international coalition they definitely
brought in other countries there
definitely was a huge coalition of
countries that went in i don't care i
don't mean for invasion i mean foreign
hey how about before we invade a country
we have
council hearings you know we we make
demands we sanction like it's really
interesting that the taliban said give
us proof bush said we don't need proof
we know he's guilty and then we're going
to war in less than a month it's like yo
yo halliburton
if you think about the timeline actually
uh from
1991 until
september 11th that's the period in time
that i call the pox americana that is
when we were cashing the peace dividend
at the end of the cold war there wasn't
any obvious international like hegemon
that could like was like challenging us
anywhere the soviet union had fallen we
had gotten so comfortable actually that
we had turned our foreign policy
attention to the western hemisphere we
were like engaging with latin america
we're going to build a free trade area
of the americas all this stuff there
wasn't any real war or military conflict
or clearly define an enemy at all
whatsoever from 91
until 2001. so it is a reasonable
presumption to make that in that
intervening 10 years
all the military-industrial complex guys
were like oh we gotta get something here
we gotta get something going we gotta
get something what's it gonna be what's
it gonna be what's it gonna be and then
iraq and then iraq and and i mean we did
have saddam hussein in the iraq thing
well we did but you know he knows
he was a boogie man but those are teeny
tiny those are teeny tiny little things
they wanted a 20-year guaranteed no-bid
contract resource extraction the whole
thing yeah yeah i'm trying to remember
um what year was uh bush's sectional
second second election was that 2002 or
four was 2004. yeah 2000 he got elected
2004 was real 2004. yeah so by the time
he makes that second inaugural and the
the goal of america is to end tyranny
around the world we had already been way
way involved so that was that wasn't
leading right i want to ask i want to go
back to the iranian revolution of 1979
this is a little bit before my time was
born in 79. but i mean they had this guy
the shaw and it was like this this 2000
year old monarchy and they they
basically i think the cia caused this
revolution this to this theocratic
uh what's this the ayatollah khamenei
this this like now they're this
theocratic muslim
well theocracy country but we basically
created that yes we did oh why i don't
know to make enemies for people in the
region
but then they then all of a sudden the
world became globalized and internet and
now yeah specifically the soviet union
is this like like the soviet union falls
and now the u.s is like okay time to
clean up the mess we made is that what
they've been doing well i mean that was
1979 the iranian revolution but after
the soviet union falls i don't know
about cleaning up the mess but it's like
expand the footprint grow the empire
more bombs more wars more money
expand them remember this is all tied at
the same time to neo
neoliberal economics which is like blow
out all the markets free trade let's
engage with china let's engage with the
every eu let's create the free trade
area of the americas which was all just
about globalized globalized globalized
so it all adds up and stacks up into the
globalization
theory this whole thing
that we're basically me and my friends
and maybe you guys are on board now i
don't know
are anti-globalization and all these
things that we're talking about are
globalization about the globalization of
american empire globalization of
american trade american values american
freedoms american all the things thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you